how is morale this morning Tim I think
it's a little down it's it's gray and
rainy here as it always is after eight
cowboys defeat especially a large one if
but we will soldier on fingers being
pointed this morning and downs I think a
lot less than usual I mean I think it's
very weird when you lose a big game like
that and about the worst that I that
some of us could come up with verse you
know why were you talking the ball in 48
seconds to go okay that wasn't an
outrageously bad decision it kind of
made sense because they were trying to
score a touchdown and it led to them
kicking the field goal a little earlier
than you would have liked but still if
you I don't think you can play thinking
well if we give Aaron Rodgers 30 seconds
we have no chance I mean you ought to be
able to stop him but nobody can right
now what did you expect yesterday I
expect to Dallas to win I mean obviously
I knew a great day about garage is great
I just thought the health of the Cowboys
I thought they'd be able to run the ball
all day which they sort of did but I
mean the defense was terrible early and
you know they weren't ready and some of
those plays Green Bay conemaugh and I
thought that was little those that was
little embarrassing and that's probably
something it would probably the most
frustrating part for the Cowboys but
then you know to come back I mean you
need 15 points and that's a long way to
go Dallas those two drives and that gets
the dew point conversion to this you
know it's a new game I thought at that
point it's you know 5050 how this is
going to go but but I mean Rajan is the
same all he was on when he will when he
won it all here six years ago he's
playing that same way and that's that's
tough to beat what's the feeling like in
the building when Rogers gets the ball
35 seconds to go I think people thought
that's a lot of time and even when
Bailey was kicking it i thought you know
if he makes it they really needed to get
it down to 15 or 20 or something because
they got timeouts you knew they had time
for 45 plays if they needed them
but I mean they got the fab it looked
like they'd they'd done their job stop
one Hail Mary keep them from going 40
yards and this thing's gonna go to
overtime and that's that throw and catch
to cook that you've been showing would
mean it's just it's just rude I don't be
else makes that throw and and a lot to
be said for cook that's why he made to
keep his feet in that's that's a
fabulous play I know Jill buck and troy
aikman visited the topic during the game
at the Tony Romo what about in the press
room did you guys bring up Tony Romo
that possibility you mean when I was 14
23 did I tweeted decision if your
annuity belt is buzzing there's
definitely some items needed rest
goodbye to pop up down I don't think
anybody thought of the logical thing to
do it wasn't selling back was playing
horribly but they were they were getting
out of it early I mean 21 the threes is
a long way to come back but but you know
it's at the md look at it and back threw
for over 300 yards he had one bad
interception you know Rogers threw an
interception so I bet it's a fun thing
to consider but it would have been a
ridiculous move at any point in time now
the question is will he will he will he
be here again and Jerry Jones insists
that he thinks you will and none of us
believes that can be true can you trade
Tony Romo and if you do how much does
dallas have to bite off here to get Romo
to wherever he wants to go or get
something in return and what do you get
in return for him I don't think you
getting vibes I mean I think it just
means people starting to execute for
pass plays in Philadelphia and if
they're going to go from that say hey
he's fine he can come play 15 games for
us good luck with that it costs money
but I mean I either what do they whether
they believe she would cost dead money
whether you train him it costs money but
the salary caps going to be 160 billion
dollars does they'll have room to do it
if they choose to do it and so I it just
it doesn't make sense to have that
you'll be 37 you evil barely played
for two years it doesn't make sense to
have him sitting around I know I know
Jerry Jones feels the exact opposite and
I know people who know him say he thinks
they need him mixture as the backup not
not as competition but I think that
would be a crazy situation to to
continue well you're saying to Tony Romo
you're not good enough for this job you
can't compete for this job I just don't
feel like Tony Romo is going to sit
there and go you know what at this point
in my life where I see some of these
other quarterbacks at my age Brady or
breeze still playing in at a high level
yeah i'm just going to accept this and
be a backup here I just can't imagine
that happening and that would loom every
time dak Prescott had a suspect game
yeah i mean i don't think i don't think
Tony has enjoyed defeated at all I think
you can see that in the brief times he
has spoken to the media and he's got to
think you know John Elway was 37 you
want his first super bowl there there
you know he probably feels like I'm
fresh I haven't played [ __ ] but I'm
fresh and didn't start playing Don 26 so
I've got years left I want to go play
and I don't blame you for feeling that
way he's tim cowlishaw in dallas morning
news and around the horn star who do you
compare the brashness of aaron rodgers
to is there another athlete who comes
come on oh I thought you could say like
Pablo Tory that bet the guy I haven't
thought of it in those terms because it
because to me it's not it is brassens
for sure but i think his answer was just
honest yesterday i mean i think he
doesn't think in a million years that
throw was that great he probably thinks
he made two or three earlier in the game
that were better than that I mean he
makes I mean his greatest Tom Brady is
he doesn't make the throws Aaron Rodgers
does he doesn't have to but but I don't
think he throws I don't think anybody
chose football like he does well that
last let you know you're going to roll
left throwback 36-yard dart keep him in
bounds long enough you know to get both
feet down and then set up the
game-winning field goal after
the previous play where you had been
sacked held onto the football you know
that's that's impressive stuff man
that's heavy stuff when you're watching
it yeah and when you rolled out laughs
everybody Cal cage this is when he
drifts off to the left that's what
you're gonna just launched the Hail
Marys got three receivers running down
the right and throw it across the field
and then it's like he sees this it's
like how did he see that window like I
can throw this laser 40-yard this guy
can keep his man who's inbound and it
worked Dallas needs to do what in the
offseason well they did they talked
about defense last year but they went to
Z Kelly around which was the way to go
how he played but but they've still got
some there as simple as much a pretender
as a contender on defense so they've got
to we've got to try to fix that up a
little bit I mean they got a lot of
people get shredded by the Packers of
the Giants beef it's pretty good they
just did but they've got to get some
some some real past rice a real ability
up front and maybe somebody in the
secondary would help to yeah although I
I mean yeah I mean you watch yesterday's
game you think that their corners are
pretty good but but Brandon Carr has
been here a long time and I don't know
what his status will be so yeah for sure
are you one around the horn tonight uh
sorry yes I am I i have a three show
week coming up where this in this era of
multiplicity a perilous don't be afraid
to do a shout out to the listeners here
because they root for you every time
that you're on I but I get a hold of
tony reality to find the lineup and
especially if you're on again splashy or
woody I I can a route for Tim Cowlishaw
Timmy needs it so don't be afraid to
give a shout out here to the program I
would like I would love to as you would
love it you where will I could love do
we take the showed the gamer will stop
rolling now I'll find a way around it
may be some sort of uh maybe some sort
of physical signal I get do you really
edit it out is that what you're saying
you take the show that they me may edit
it out the should happen okay on it but
that doesn't mean that doesn't mean I
won't be out there trying I appreciate
that I appreciate that thank you Tim
thanks buddy that's a gym cabochon
Dallas Morning News the Dan Patrick show
weekday morning on audience
[Music]